orca they said they were just counting
the moments until they could get
inside that brand new resort resorts
world las vegas
on the las vegas strip now many we spoke
to were actually
las vegas locals they said they were
happy to come down to be part of this
slice of history
from what i see everything looks great
after so much anticipation
resorts world las vegas is finally here
watching it be built and open finally
now that it's open we caught up with the
crowds
as they arrived for thursday night's
grand opening event
and the excitement was palpable it's
just amazing and then
like the time it's happening is just
awesome many from right here in the
valley were happy to make their way down
for the first from the ground resort the
strip has seen
in over a decade i've been here for a
lot of them
a lot of them i watched them and implode
the stardust as a matter of fact they
said they didn't want to miss
this classic vegas moment they know
we'll all
remember forever this is a strip so it's
really cool
it's kind of a part of history ever
since the riviera was gone
now lines started forming tonight around
8 30 9 o'clock p.m
actually the first 2 000 people in line
at 9 00
were allowed to come in and kind of have
an outdoor celebration
with the dj in front of the resort and
of course the rain we saw tonight
did not stop people from coming out
reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now